nous avons décidé que nous devions
vérifier s'il y avait lieu d'engager les
procédures de l'article 4 du traité
d'alliance militaire de l'OTAN
autrement vérifier si l'intégrité ou la
sécurité du pays est menacé dans le
cratère formé par l'explosion les
enquêteurs s'activent c'est ici hacher
vos dofes qu'un missile s'est écrasé
hier si Joseph la dernière fois qu'on a
attaqué la Pologne ça c'est mal terminé
disons-le et on pensait à ça hier soir
avec ces deux quoi moi je pensais à ça
en tout cas avec ces deux missiles les
analyses sont en cours nous coopérons
avec la Pologne pour savoir exactement
ce qui s'est passé et nous le faisons
avec l'ensemble des alliés avec lesquels
nous nous sommes réunis ce matin la
Pologne les pays baltes ce n'est qu'une
question de temps pour que la terreur
russe aille plus loin il est nécessaire
de remettre à sa place l'état terroriste
plus longtemps la Russie se sentira
impuni plus il y aura de menaces pour
tous ceux qui peuvent être atteints par
les missiles russes Moscou en défend et
assure qu'il s'agit de missiles
Ukrainiens anti-aériens réunis en sommet
du G20 en Indonésie les chefs d'État
occidentaux temporisent car la Pologne
est membre de l'OTAN une attaque russe
sur son sol entraînerait alors une
réponse collective de l'Alliance rien
indique qu'il s'agisse d'une attaque
délibérée de la Russie
et nous n'avons aucune indication que la
Russie prépare des actions militaires
offensives contre l'OTAN il est
improbable d'après la trajectoire du
missile qu'il était tiré depuis la
Russie on verra confirmation quelques
heures plus tard d'après les Américains
il s'agirait d'un tir de la défense
entière et Yann ukrainienne si blanc
probablement un engin russe
qui n'aspire qu'à une chose c'est à une
troisième guerre mondiale qui règlerait
le problème de son puissant voisin
évidemment les autres sont davantage
dans la retenue des informations
rejetées ce matin encore par le
président ukrainien dans un message
adressé au G20 cette attaque de missile
est un message de la Russie adressé au
G20 parce que la Russie est un état
terroriste et nous nous défendons contre
elle arrêtons de faire de la politique
fiction réjouissons-nous que nous ne
soyons pas dans la situation que le de
faire fonctionner l'article 5 qui est en
train de Ringer mondiale car je crois
que personne ne souhaite
la mondialisation de ce conflit c'est
entretenu avec le Premier ministre
polonais pour lui assurer la totale
solidarité de la France la Pologne c'est
un pays qui manque de l'OTAN qui manque
de l'Union européenne et donc nous
serons évidemment solidaires oui la
Pologne est un pays ami de la France
bien entendu si elle avait été
volontairement attaquée sur son
territoire elle pourrait bien entendu
compter sur la solidarité française je
le dis au vatangière qu'on entend sur
les plateaux télé derrière la souffrance
des Ukrainiens la faiblesse de la Russie
c'est comment dire le déclin de l'Europe
tout entière c'est le sacrifice de
l'économie allemande de l'économie
française c'est la souffrance des
Français et c'est la sortie de
l'histoire de l'Europe afin de rendre sa
grandeur et sa gloire à notre pays
j'annonce ma candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
44 des 234 rescapés de lotion viking
seront expulsés de France dès que leur
état de santé le permettra leur demande
d'asile a été refusé à déclarer hier
Gérald Darmanin libre grâce à des vis de
procédures hier 4 migrants hospitalisés
à Bastia ont été autorisés par la
justice à quitter la zone d'attente de
hier et à faire une demande d'asile dans
les 8 jours qui peut comprendre que dans
un pays comme le nôtre on ne soit pas
capable de traiter 234 dossiers en 4
jours tiens
décollage d'Artémis 1
nous nous élançons ensemble vers la lune
et au-delà une dernière image furtive de
la terre puis direction la lune retour
prévu dans 25 jours et 2 millions de
kilomètres